hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the second of October and you're
tuned into gamespot news first up xbox
one exclusive d4 is never going to come
to the ps4 according to its creator hit
Atticus were here better known by his
nickname sweary has replied sorry never
to a Twitter fan asking if the game
would make it onto Sony's new gen
console he went on to say you can't play
d4 on ps4 forever sorry have to buy an
xbox one or find a kind friend so
although ps4 seems to be a no go there
is a possibility of the game coming to
PC since in regard to that query swear I
only commented that he was currently
committed to doing promotion for the
xbox one version a Bible game which is
currently making its way through
Kickstarter has been submitted to Sony
for approval across its platforms the
game's creators the tornador twins
announced the news in a Kickstarter
update the game which is actually called
the Bible game is set to unfold in 10
installments which in the devs words aim
to turn the world's most loved book into
a quality game they also have said they
wanted to make a game about the Bible
that isn't full of gore appeals all ages
isn't cheesy and is true to the Bible
the game has not been funded at this
time and has 29 days to go in its
Kickstarter campaign the GTA online
update has landed and if you're still
thinking hours into the title here's
what you want to know the last team
standing update introduces new equipment
weapons and vehicles creative features
and ten new jobs to get stuck into no
word yet on when gamers will see heists
added to the online mode since they were
delayed back in June you can find all
the nitty-gritty details of the update
in our story on site including all the
specifics on the new last team standing
jobs which range from ranked 9 2 ranked
36 in counters alongside the added
features is a big list of fixes and
tweaks ask you a question of the day let
me know if you're still playing GTA
online and what you reckon about the
Bible in game
on as for more newsy bits and pieces
we've got footage of the apples of
blood-borne on site now that is it for
me today I'll be back tomorrow with my
top five stories of the whole gaming
week so I hope to catch you then